herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren wenn eine koalition nicht das
rückgrat hat sich mit den wirklichen
klima sondern anzulegen dann kommt genau
das heraus was sie am freitag hier
vorgelegt haben
ein flickenteppich an subventionen und
ein sinnloses abkassieren der
verbraucher dass die soziale spaltung
weiter vertieft und genau die wieder am
härtesten trifft die sich von ihnen
sowieso schon seit vielen jahren im
stich gelassen fühlen
das weltklima werden sie so ganz
bestimmt nicht retten aber sie werden
das politische und soziale klima in
unserem land weiter verschlechtern denn
wer so vorgeht
der erzeugt ängste und er sorgt dafür
dass klimaschutz bei den ärmeren und bei
der unteren mittelschicht immer
unpopulärer wird wir finden das
unverantwortlich dabei legt dabei liegt
das hauptproblem ihres vorschlags nicht
sagen dass einem 3 cent verteuert der
spritpreis niemanden dazu bringen wird
sein auto stehen zu lassen
das hauptproblem liegt daran dass selbst
eine verdoppelung der benzinpreise
nichts daran ändern würde dass viele
menschen in diesem land schlicht keine
alternative zum auto haben worauf sollen
sie dann
umsteigen auf nahverkehrszüge und busse
die es in vielen regionen überhaupt
nicht mehr gibt
sie waren es doch sie waren es doch die
aus der bahn
eine börsen warten wollten mit dem
ergebnis dass ein fünftel des
streckennetzes stillgelegt wurde
das notwendige investitionen
unterblieben sind und dass die
ticketpreise immer teurer wurden heute
rollen profico london über die autobahn
während die bahn jetzt schon wieder
radikale kürzungen in ihrer gütersparte
angekündigt hat und es ist denn das für
eine unsinnige politik und sie waren es
auch die die privatisierung öffentlicher
dienste in den letzten jahren immer
weiter vorangetrieben haben
die die busse und busverbindungen in
vielen ländlichen bereichen schlicht zum
verschwinden gebracht haben und die auch
dazu beigetragen haben dass wohnraum in
die großen städten immer teurer geworden
ist und das ist einer der wesentlichen
gründe warum viele menschen immer
längere arbeitswege in anspruch nehmen
müssen und erscheint mir scheint auch
nicht nur herr hubble hat wissenslücken
in bezug auf die pendlerpauschale
also wenn sie behaupten dass die
steigenden benzinpreise durch die
erhöhung der pauschale ausgeglichen oder
zumindest abgefedert werden dann
scheinen sie schlicht nicht zu wissen
dass geringverdiener von dieser erhöhung
überhaupt nichts haben weil sie zahlen
nicht so viel steuern dass sie dort mehr
absetzen können
und natürlich etwas anders natürlich
geht es anders in der schweiz die
schweiz zb investiert pro kopf fünfmal
soviel in ihr schienennetz wie
deutschland und in anderen metropolen
bringt der elektrifizierte nahverkehr
die menschen im drei minuten takt von a
nach b
warum setzen sie sich zum beispiel nicht
dafür ein dass die ezb die jetzt schon
wieder konzern anleihen kaufen will dass
die ihre milliarden lieber in gute
vernünftige öffentliche verkehrsprojekte
in ganz europa investiert das wird ein
echter beitrag zum klimaschutz
und ganz nebenbei wäre auch ein gutes
konjunkturprogramm angesichts der
heraufziehenden wirtschaftskrise ihre
politik passt vorn und hinten nicht
zusammen
sie wollen dass die menschen weniger
fliegen aber gleichzeitig treiben sie
immer neue freihandelsabkommen voran so
wie aktuell das mit dem mercosur die die
globalen transport emission in immer
neue rekordhöhen treiben un klima
experten schätzen dass etwa ein viertel
aller klimaschädlichen emissionen heute
auf die globalen warenströme zurückgehen
ein viertel so viele kohlekraftwerke
können sie überhaupt nicht abschalten um
den schaden auch nur ansatzweise
auszugleichen die in jedes neue
freihandelsabkommen klimapolitisch
anrichtet und da sollten sie es
was produzieren echter klimaschutz ist
doch natürlich unmöglich solange wir
nahrungsmittel die auch hier bei uns
wachsen über tausende kilometer
entfernung hierher kommt ihren und
solange unzählige industriegüter nur
deshalb in riesigen schmutzigen
containerschiffen quer von einem
kontinent zum anderen schippern weil
dadurch konzerne lohnkosten drücken und
standards unterlaufen können über zwei
drittel aller globalen co2 emissionen
werden heute von 100 multinationalen
konzernen verursacht und stadt diese
klimakiller endlich mit gesetzlichen
auflagen zur veränderung zu zwingen
wollen sie das heizen normaler familien
teurer machen
das ist doch pure klima heuchelei was
sie hier betreiben
wir wollten wirklich
wir brauchen wirklich nicht noch
zusätzliche subventionen für behäbige
großkonzerne sondern was wir brauchen
ist eine förderung innovativer
neugründungen
wir brauchen wieder eine eigene
solarindustrie die sie sträflich haben
kaputt gehen lassen
und wir brauchen staatliche milliarden-
investitionen in die erforschung grüner
technologien weil der markt das eben
nicht allein richtet und herr lindner
ist ist ja schön wenn sich an die
synthetische kraftstoffe erinnern die
autokonzerne haben in den letzten fünf
jahren über 100 milliarden euro gewinn
gemacht und was haben sie mit diesem
gewinn gemacht sie haben es nicht
investiert in die erforschung grüner
antriebstechnologien sondern sie haben
es großen da ist an ihre eigentümer
ausgeschüttet und das ist eben tragen
das große problem weil damit werden
1000 industrie arbeitsplätze hier in
deutschland in gefahr gebracht
und deswegen brauchen wir einen
handlungsfähigen staat und eben nicht so
eine koalition wie wir sie haben
wir brauchen eine politik mit rückgrat
und mut die gemeinsam mit den jungen
menschen dafür kämpft dass unsere welt
nicht den profitinteressen weniger
geopfert wird
[Applaus]